よろしくお願いします
直接テーマに入ってお話しさせていただきます
間違いだらけの善悪判断というテーマでございますが
一応 善悪判断というのはどういうものかということを
できるだけ簡単にお話しさせていただきます
善悪という問題だけは
仏教の話の中で一番簡単な話だと思います
そんなに難しいことではありません
世の中でどう考えていらっしゃるかわかりませんけど
仏教の話の中でもっと難しい真理の話っていうのはすごく難しいかもしれませんけど
善悪判断というのはとても簡単で
一番わかりやすいところなんです
ですから
今日の話
あまりわかりやすくなるものだから
ちょっと難しくして喋ろうかなと
難しくするためというわけでもなくて
一番先にこの釈尊の時代であったあることをご紹介させていただきます
どういうことかというと
我々現代人にとっては
超能力っていうのは大変不思議な現象で
誰かに何かあると言っちゃったら
さっとそこに人が集まって
いろいろなことをやったり
大変いろんなことをやってましたけど
当時釈尊がいたこの紀元前
6 世紀あたりでは
インドとしてはそんなに不思議なことでもなく
ごく一般的に行者の中であった現象なんですね
いわゆる昔は
この何か修行する
精神的な心の訓練をするということは
一般的に身についてない
いろんな能力がつくということを当たり前で考えていたんです
昔と今の違うところは
それは商売にしなかったということだけなんです
インド文化っていうのは
商売は商売で
それ終わってから 子供たちも大きくなるし
自分でもう財産を持って自分で社会人になってくると
社会から離れて修行の世界に入っちゃうんですね
もう金は財産は要りませんと
もう名誉も何も要りませんと
ただ単に知識と知恵だけ求めていきますと
まず知識的な仕事のための勉強をして
それから商売やったら
いろんなことをなさってから
それは終わりましたと
終わってから心の勉強をしようと
心の勉強にはもうお金やら家族やら邪魔ですから
それは置いておいて修行に励むんですね
ですから
この出家する現象っていうのは
インドにとっては 当たり前の現象でもありましたし
でもほとんどの人々はやっぱり子供たちが大きくなって独立してから出家するんですね
出家にも形がなかったんだけど
自分勝手に誰かの先生のところに行って
それなりに出家だと思って修行していたんですね
家族を持ってない
財産を持ってないということで出家と申していたんだから
それを変えたのは釈尊なんですね
そんないい加減に好き勝手に出家したとしても意味がないと
その人々はparibbājakaという言葉で
インドの言葉で使ってるんですね
パーリ語でparibbājakaというんですね
サンスクリット語でparibrājaka
あるいはBでもいいし V
でもいいんです
日本語と同じです
で パーリ語で
paribbājaka
サンスクリット語だったらBの代わりにV書いても構いません
VとBがいつでも
同じ価値なんですね
パーリ語ではそれほどなくないんです
決まってるんです
paribbājaka
このparibbājakaっていうのは
pariっていうのはぐるぐる
bājakaっていうのは歩くということで
あっちこっち歩き回るということで
英語でこのwandererという言葉使ってます
ですから
wanderer
別に特別な目的があるわけじゃなくて
あっちこっち歩くと
で この出家する人々はだいたい決まってる場所がなくて
あっちこっち歩いて歩いて歩いて
いろんな先生たちに出会ったり
修行したり見たりとか
そういう生活をしていたんですね
お釈迦様はそういうふうに
あまりこのシステムがなく
出家する人々はparibbājakaということで
仏教とはもう違うということになっていたんですね
仏教ではちゃんとこの出家するならば
それなりの決まりがあって
その決まりに沿って生き方があって
ちゃんと出家しなくちゃいけないし
でも仏教の出家にも自分にもいる家というものはない
ですから
毎日どこかへ歩いて
そこら辺でどこかで寝泊まりすれば結構と
釈尊はそういうふうになさっていたんだけど
どんどん仏教にはいろいろお寺やらいろんなことできてきたんだから
いろんなところ住むところはできてきたんですね
それでその話は置いておいて
その人々には結構いろんな能力あった人々がいたんです
その修行者の中で
自分たちが修行しているにも関わらず
全く善悪を否定する人々がいたんです
善と悪ということはもうないんだと
全く否定するんです
そこでその修行して
その結果で善悪はないというのはいいんだけど
一般の人々にそんなことを話しちゃうと
善も悪もないと言っちゃったら
人を殺しても人を助けてあげたとしても
もう大したことがないんだと
同じだと
人にものを与えたとしても
人のものを奪ったとしても
結局行為にしか過ぎないんだと
ただの行為だけであって
例えば自分の持っているものを人にあげる人の持ってるものを自分が奪う
ただものはこちらから向こう側
向こう側からこちら側と動いただけのことではないかと
そこに何の価値判断も道徳的な判断はできませんと
いわゆる善悪はないと徹底的に言ってるんですね
だから話だけ聞けば
ちょっと危ない話なんですけど
その方々にはそれなりの訳があったんですね
お釈迦様はそのわけを説明するんです
お釈迦様はある日こう言うんですね
ある行者たちには
もう何か人間に超越した
能力 知識
知恵を得て
それで過去を観察するんだと
あるいは人の命を観察してみるんだと
見たら彼らに見えるんですね
例えば 人々が生きてる姿
全然いいことをしないで
殺生したり
嘘を言ったり
他の邪な行為をしたり
まあありとあらゆる悪いことをしていて
それでその人は死んでしまったところはどこに生まれ変わったかと見るんだと
見たら何のことなくいいところに生まれ変わっているんだと
それを見たら自分の経験だから
これは何だと
あの人は大変悪いことばっかりしていたのに
死んでしまったところでいいところに生まれ変わってるじゃないですか
ということは
世の中で悪いことをするなかれと
悪いことをしたら悪い結果が罰が当たるよというのは
いい加減でたらめではないかと
なぜならば
自分の超能力で見たところで
悪いことをした人はもういいところに生まれ変わっているのは見たんだから
と　この超能力で体験するものは
目で見るよりはものすごいしっかりした体験だそうですね
そこでまた他の人々のことを観察すると
例えばいいことをしている人々
ずっといいことをしていて
死んでしまったところで
どこに生まれ変わったかを見たら
ああ かわいそうに
悪いところに落ちているんだと
不幸なところに
それを見たら
またさらに自分の考え方は強くしちゃうんですね
結局はでたらめだと
いいことをしたらいい結果がでるんだ
悪いことをしたら悪い結果がでるんだというのは
まああまり根拠のないでたらめの言い方だと
と決めてしまう
それにはお釈迦様は
このあるお経でそれは説明して
その方々はもっと明確に観察した方が良かったのではないかと
彼らの経験は間違っていると言ってないんです
それはまあ
超能力で見たものだから
それはその通りですよと
でももっと明確に見た方が良かったのではないかと
いわゆるたった一つの出来事だけを見て
これでこの結果だよというのはちょっと早すぎだと
その人々が
例えば悪いことをしていいところに生まれたと
でもその人々がその生まれる
死んで生まれ変わる前に心を清らかにしていたかもしれませんし
あるいはもっと前にやったいいことを思い出して
死ぬ時は心が明るくなった可能性あるんだと
そこが心は明るくなったんだから
そこでいいところに生まれてしまうんだと
ずっといいことをしていたとしても
死ぬ時はすごく暗い心で死んでしまったら
しょうがなく
次の生は悪いところに生まれ変わっちゃうんだよと
そこら辺はあまり考えてないんだと
それから善悪の結果の場合は
こういう例えを使ってるんですね
a pinch of saltと英語で言えば
日本語で何と言いますかね
英語で　このほんの塩の一欠片という意味で a pinch of salt というんで
昔の塩っていうのは粉じゃないんです
それはご存知ですね
海から取って
自然に蒸発して
また塩が下に溜まったらかなり大きいんですね
あれは砕いて大きな粒にしちゃうんです
今我々が見ているような
きめ細かい粉になるわけじゃないんです
ですから
一つの塩ひとかけらというお経でこう言うんですね
こんな小さな水に
ほんの少々の水に塩を溶かしたら
ひとかけら塩を溶かしちゃったらどうですかと
そうすると
水がものすごく塩味がするのではないかと
かなり大量の水にひとかけらの塩を入れて溶かしても
全然塩の味がしないんだと
美味しい水の味しかしませんと
そのように心の状態によって
心は育てていない
心は狭い
小さい　そういう心で微かな悪いことをしても
すごい大きな結果が出てくるんだと
そこで大きな心の人が
たまたま何か悪いことをしたとしても
そんなに効き目がないんだと
それは
自分の心は小さな茶碗みたいな小さなものか
大きなものかということの問題で
心を育ててほしいということをお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんですね
それでもう一つの宗教家がこう言うんですね
いわゆる行為論
アクティビティ
アクション
行為 行動
世の中にあるのは行動のみと
だから何か物があるんじゃなくて
いろんな働きはあるんだと
それだけちょっと考えると
すごい科学的な考え方なんですね
運動ということだからね
行動 運動
他のものはないんだと
そこで行動のみであるならば
そこにどうやって善悪判断できるんですかと
ものは動いている
いわゆるものというものはありません
ものっていうのは
また動きにものというだけであって
人間というのはある動きに人間と言うのであって
その動きが手を挙げて人をぶっても
それは一つの動きだけであると
動きには何の善悪があるんですかと
ですから
人を殺すことも行為であって
人を助けることも行為であって
それによって云々というなと言って善悪を否定する
行為論を持って
もう一人の宗教者がいて
実体論を喋っているんですね
元素論　で
元素論といっても
科学的な元素というよりは
だいたい ７つの元素で全てができているんだと
それはパトリシアとジェワヨと六根とジーワというライフですね
そういう ７つなんですけど
７つの元素でできていて
その元素だからもう何も変化はしないんだと
科学の元素論から見ても
元素は元素で
そのまんまで
私は水を飲んだとしても
水には水素
酸素あるだけで
水素
酸素としては別にもう変わりはないんですね
元に戻ってもらうことはできるんです
水は水で違うものかもしれませんけど
水はまた水素と酸素に分けてもらうことはできるんですね
そういう風にこの
じゃあそれだったら水になったんだからといって酸素に何かなったんですか？
元素に水素は何かなったんですか？
と　何もなってないんですね
結局は　ですから
すべては元素で出来上がっているんだから
例えば人が人を殺すという場合は
その人はその前にある元素の塊の中にちょっと穴を開けるだけですよと
そこに殺した人もいないし
殺された人もいませんと
ですから
善悪っていうのはありえないと話してるんです
そういう風にすごい力強く喋ってるんだから
運命論を喋っている人もいるんですね
世の中は運命で定めているんだと
我々の好き勝手に物事は動かないんだと
物事にはそれなりの理由
それなりの動き方があるんだと
そういえばそれも理解できるでしょうに
我々世の中を見ていると
もう簡単に自分勝手にはうまくいかないんですね
例えば 季節がありまして
季節が出てくると
その通りに我々の体も変化する
植物も変化する
それはどうしようもないんです
今頃になったら桜が咲くと
それ止めようとしたとしても止められませんし
冬は桜咲いてほしいと思ったとしても咲いてくれませんし
で　そのようにして
この地球もそのように回転して回転して
やがて消えてしまうとかね
それは決まってるんだと
物事決まっているならば
私は人を殺したとしても
それは決まっているものであって
私に何の責任もあるわけじゃないんです
私は殺されたとしても
それは悔しがったりすることの何の意味もないんだと
それはそういう決まりだよと
人が事故を起こして死んじゃっても
そういう定めだからということで
もう決まりという定め論
運命論を持ってきて
もう善と悪っていうのはないんだと
世の中で人は殺人者になるならばそういう運命であって
大泥棒になっているならばそういう運命であって
もう人には何も自由意志というものはありませんと
人間が自分の意志で堂々と元気に生きているわけじゃないと言っている人もいたんです
そういう一つ一つ
すごい力強い教えなんです
また 悪いことに
そういう人々は結構修行したりして
かなり普通の人間よりすごい高いレベルの智慧も持っていたんですね
だから大変な状態なんです
その環境背景の中で釈尊が善悪のことを教えたんです
ですから
なんかちょっと難しくなっちゃうかもしれませんけど
そういうことだから
私は今日申し上げたいのは
ですから
人間にはこのやたらにこれは悪い
これは正しいと言えるものじゃないということなんです
あれほどの
我々にはもう何の超能力もないし
空を飛べることもできないし
土の中に潜ることもできないし
電車がなければもう大変ですね
歩いてここまで来なくちゃいけないし
瞬間移動とかあるならば大変便利でいいんだけど
なかなかそんなことはないし
だからそういういろんな能力がついてる人々が
善もない悪もないと
善も不善も存在しないよと言うならば
私たちはもうどうしようかと
私たちの判断はどうしようかと
ですから
まず理解しておいてほしいのは
このやたらにこれは善だ
これは不善だ
それは悪だと決めることは不可能であると
ですから
私たちの善悪判断は間違いだらけというならば
それはその通りなんです
しょうがないんですね
でも しょうがないと言ったとしても
それで物事済むわけじゃないんです
どう見たとしても
悪いことをしてはいけないんです
いいことはするべきなんですね
そういう論理も世の中にあるんですね
常識として
ですから
お釈迦様はあの超能力者たちの教えを
もう危ないんだと
人の成長を妨げているんだと
人の努力を否定しているんだという立場で悪いと決めているんです
そこで我々に一つの善悪判断の基準が出てくるんです
どういうことかというと
例えば人を殺しても殺されても何のこともないんだと思ったら
じゃあ思う存分人殺したらいいんですかと
自分の両親も何か言ったら
両親を殺してしまうと
子供はわがまま言っちゃったらもう殺してしまうとか
そういうふうに生きていられますかというと
それは無理なんですね
罪がないんだと
ですから
その行者たちも
結局何をいいことしたとしても結果がないんだ
悪いことしたとしても悪い結果がないんだと言いながら
自分たちが一生懸命行者なんですね
修行者なんですね
だからお釈迦様があなた方なんで矛盾なことを言ってるんですかと
なんで修行しているんですかと
それは定めだというでしょ
あなた方もかわいそうですね
修行する定めになっちゃって
何か贅沢する定めになった方がもっと便利なのにとかね
そういう感じで言ってることは矛盾だから
それから社会の立場から見れば
それではうまくいかない
そういうことで
あまり相手にしなくてもいい話だと置いておく
そこで釈尊がそれを批判する場合は
こういう言葉を使ってたんですね
人間の努力を人間
これより良くなりましょうという希望
気持ちがあるんですね
常に我々には良くなってやると
もっと立派になりますという気持ちがある
自分のレベルをほんの微かでもいいから
わずかでもいいから
ちょっとレベルを高くしたいんだと
それにはものすごいダメージを与えているんですね
このもし善悪判断はないという場合は
それで仏教の善悪判断の第一番目の基準
そこにあるんです
何ですかというと
人は努力するべき
成長するべきですということ
今の状態よりもっといい状態に進歩するべきですと
その目的で考えちゃうと
人間の生き方
進歩させる
成長させる道
方法 行為が善行為になるんです
すごい数学みたいに簡単でしょ
道徳判断というのは
それを覚えておいてください
私はこういう同じテーマも大学で専門分野としてやっていたんだから
もう難しく
もう学問的に喋るならばサッサッサッと喋れますけど
その場合はなかなかこの単語は英語でしか頭に出てこないんです
それ難しいんですけど
ですから
この　ちょっと苦労しますけど
何が善ですか？
何が悪ですかと決められない時は
我々はどんな行動をすると
どんな行為をすると
私たちは成長しますか？
より良くなりますか？
我々のレベルがより高くなりますかと
その道が
その行為が善行為であって
人間の道が堕落するならば
それは不善行為であると決める
それで問題が一体成長って何ですかと
今の状態より良くなるということは何ですかと
そこで私たちは
2つ考えられるんですね
1つは物質的な豊かさ
発展　もう一つは精神的な豊かさ
発展　そこで
1番目の物質的な豊かさ
それまた 2種類に分けられます
1番目は
我々生きている環境を発展させる
ということは
例えば建物を作る
電車を作る
飛行機を作るとか
そういう風にこの環境を発展させて
人間が物質的に豊かになる
より立派になる
そうでしょう
それでそちらの
2番目は
自分の体のこと
より健康的で
病気を抑えて長生きできるようにと
という発展
その両方
そこでより健康的で長生きする場合は
それには社会は必要であるし
家族が必要であるし
他の人々の関係は必要であるし
みんなと喧嘩しながら長生きしたとしても意味がない
みんなに嫌われて
追い出されて
社会から
誰からも助けてくれないで
不幸だらけでずっと長生きしているんだと言ったとしても
なんか面白くないんですね
ですから
健康的で長生きするという目的になってくると
そこでもう社会と家族とどううまくいけますかということを考えなくちゃいけないんです
それは物質的な成長
2種類言いましたから
で 一つは環境を変えていく
環境はより立派に生きやすい環境にしていく
もう一つは
自分の体のことを考えてみると
その両方を物質的な世界に入れていくんですね
じゃあ 精神的なことに入る前に
これについてもうちょっと考えてみましょう
仏教から見れば
この物質的な豊かさは決して否定してないんです
たまになんか人々は宗教なんかは
このインドの宗教なんかは
人間の物質的な豊かさ発展というのは馬鹿にしているんだと
だから貧しいまんまではないかと
言われたりすることもありますけど
それは事実ではありません
で 人間頑張って努力する
それで環境を自分により良い環境に変える
それは決して否定してないんです
ですから
そこで問題は
必死になって環境を変えることだけ
建物を造ることだけ
高速道路を造ることだけ
車や飛行機やらを作ることだけ
人間の目的になったらなんか面白くないんじゃないですかと
ただの物を作る作り屋さんだけで人生終わるんじゃないかと
それだけなんですね
それで今
我々現代社会で知っていることは
この物質的な豊かさだけを見て頑張ってるんだから
我々は大変な危険な状態になってるんです
もう自然は壊されてるんです
自然のままでもう生きていられなくなってるんです
資源は消えていくんです
もう原子力発電所とかなんとかあるんだけど
危なくてしょうがないんですね
それでみんなもういい加減
あまりにも自信があって
日本の原子力発電というのは
もう技術能力は世界一流で
決して事故なんかは起こりっこないんですよとか
もう散々自慢していて
それで事故を起こす
起こしても対処できない
自慢ばっかりしてるんだから完全バカなんですね
どうすればいいかわからない
どれぐらい放射能が環境に入ったかともわからない
わかっても言わない
徹底的にそれは秘密にすると
そういうふうなところまでなってしまうんです
ですから
もうエネルギーは必要だ
必要だと
もう自然のエネルギーはもう使い切って
そうすると核兵器のエネルギー
核のエネルギーに行かなくちゃいけない
それまたすごい危険なものです
ですから
物質的な豊かさだけ考えると
それは偏見的であって
人間の豊かさは考えてないんですね
いわゆる生きている人のことは考えてない
あんた方は死んでもいいんだと
我々は自然のいろんなものを
建物を作ったり
山を全部切っちゃって
もうそこでまた住宅を造ったりしますよと
それ買いなさいと
それからあなた方死んでしまって
それは知りませんよという無責任な態度をとってるんですね
その科学世界
我々生きている世界
その無責任な態度をとると
私たちの成長したくても成長できなくなっちゃうんですね
元気で生きていたくても
元気で生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
長生きしたくても長生きできなくなっちゃうんですね
たとえ今のこの空気の中で放射能あるかないかわからないでしょうに
全然わからない
知らないうちに体に恐ろしい毒が入っちゃう
今電波障害ありまして
それまた
20年ぐらい経ったところで
我々の体にどんな変化が起こるかわからない
すぐその場で何も結果が見えませんから
それは売りさばきましょうと言って
片っ端から売りさばく
一番最近も出てくるのは
このデジタルコミュニケーションですか
もうデジタル方式にコミュニケーションしようと思って
もう地球の周り
宇宙の周りはもう場所がないほど衛星ばっかり
もう衛星のゴミにしちゃって
もう地球に電波を送ってるんですね
そこでアミューズメント情報にしても
昨日テレビで見たんだけど
いろいろ放送局がもう
100ch
200ch
ぐらい見られますよとか思って
膨大な計画を立てて事業を始める
始める場合は
なかなか一般の人々はあまりにも高くて買わない
そうすると自分たちが投資したお金が戻ってこない
それで国際貿易なんとかと会議を作っちゃって
他の国々にあなた方はちゃんとこれ買いなさいと
あなた方の国々は情報に開放しなさいと
ものすごいきつく命令するんですね
最近そういう契約を交わしちゃったんだから
地球スケールでも情報はもう開放してあげるんだと
それを何のためかというと
このアメリカとか
そういう国々が膨大なお金を投資して作っている
デジタル放送システムを世界中売りさばかないと
自分の元は戻らないだけのことなんですね
そこで脅かされて
アジアとかそういう人々は
ああいう高価なものを買わなくちゃいけない
もし買わなかったら
もう割り当て決めちゃうんですね
随分勝手でわがままで
でも誰一人それは勝手だとわがままだと思わない
あ すごい最新的な発展ではないかと
その発展には閉鎖しているのはかわいそうだと
なんで国々はそんな制限するんだとか
またもうこういうところで騙されて
ですから
そういうふうな物質的な文明は本当に善悪判断ではどうでしょうかと
だから考えましょう
仏教から見れば
自然を我々により楽に
より楽しく生きられるために
回転させるというか
発展する
それは善行為でありますよ
例えば 皆様方は今日こちらへいらっしゃったのは電車があったからなんです
もし電車がなかったら
まあ明日からでも出発しなきゃ来られないぐらい遠いところからもこちらにいらっしゃっているんだから
明日夜でも出発しないと間に合わない
でもそういうことじゃなくて
まあちょっと
1時間ぐらい先に出られれば
もうここにいるんですから
それは楽なんですね
そこで今日講義終わったら
どこかで泊まるんじゃなくて
何のことなく自分の家に戻られますから
まあ 大阪からいらっしゃる方はいませんけど
この講義終わったら大阪にでも帰られますから
帰って昼ご飯食べられますからね
それは便利といえばすごい便利なんですね
ですから人間に便利ですから
人間の役に立ってますから
そういう行為は善行為なんです
いいことなんです
そこで次に人間所詮バカだから
ものを作ることを大事であって
人はどうでもいいと思って
ありとあらゆるものを発展させちゃう
そこで我々の命さえ脅かされている
どんな病気にかかるかわからない
病気治そうと思って大学の病院に行っちゃったら
薬も効かない病気を作って入れてもらうと
そういう状態になっているんですね
そこであまりにも医学なんか発展しすぎて
もうさっぱりお医者さんも何もわからない
血管だけ勉強したお医者さんが血管のことはわかるんだけど
人のこと全くわからない
ただ いらないところは全部切って捨てる
切って捨てるやり方でやっているんですね
そこでたまにほんの微かな体の部分が
もうやり直しは効かないと思ったら切って捨ててもいいんだけど
そこで切って捨てる専門家が出てくるんですね
医者の場合もすごいかっこいいのは外科なんですね
このテレビドラマなんか見たら
医者が出たらみんな確実に外科なんですね
どれほど人間バカかというと
それからあのついでに言いますけど
ドラマではもし学校なんか出たら
先生は必ず英語を教えているんです
見てください
それは二つしかないんです
そこで何かテキストを開けて読むだけ
それもお腹が痛くなるほど気持ち悪い発音で
だからドラマっていうのはかっこよく見せることだから
自分でかっこよく喋ることを喋ってね
授業の演技やればいいのに
あれはなんだかわかりません
私は
とにかくこの医学はそういうふうに発展して
じゃあいらないものはもう切って捨てろ
切って捨てろと
でもそれ考えると体に必要なもので体の部分を切って捨てると
その人は生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
ちょっと癌だといって
そこは全部捨てちゃったら
それっきりで
その人は寝たきりで
1年  2年
3年生きていなくちゃいけない
切ってしまったとしても
まあ あと
2年ですよ
3年ですよと
切らなかったら
切らなかったらせいぜい
3年ですよと言うんですね
どっちでも同じことなんですね
ですから
切って捨てることもある程度でいいんだけど
だからといってあんまりにもその技術が発達して
なんでもかんでも切って捨てるようになっちゃったら
あれは医学ではなくて人殺し学になっちゃうんですね
だから法律的に人を殺せるのはお医者さんだけなんです
とにかく裁判なんかはものすごいきついんですよ
人を死刑に処刑するのは
処刑に決めちゃっても
処刑するかしないかまた後で考えますから
まあ 例えば日本のような国だったら
本当に死刑にしますかないかとか考えて考えて
延期して延期して
まあ後でも忘れて
そのままもうスルスルと置いておくかとかね
そういう風にもなりますけど
ですから
法律にさえない権利が
もう医者にあるんですね
だからそこまで道徳的ですかと
と考えてほしいんです
ですから
もうそういうふうに仏教の立場で我々は
この私は間違いだらけの善悪と言ったならば
面白くて聞きやすいんだけど
やっぱり説法しなくちゃいけないんだから
もうやっぱりこれはこういう判断だよと言った方が
まあまあ私にとっては納得いくんです
皆様を喜ばせてあげるよりは
ですから
また戻って説明いたします
仏教においては
物質的な発展は善たる行為だと見ています
でも だからといって
それを一方的に決めちゃったら
それは人殺し道具になってしまう
人間が苦しまれることになってしまう
ですから
ほどほどにしろということは必要なんです
なんでもかんでも発展発展ということはちょっと良くない
で この体の発展についての体
健康的に長生きするのは素晴らしいことで
ですから
仏教ではこの善行為のことを言う場合は
医者さん
お医者さんの仕事
治療すること
看病すること
病気の人を助けることっていうのは最高
ものすごい高い価値の善行為だと言っているんです
お釈迦様はある日こう言うんです
もし人が患者さんの面倒を見るならば
心を極めて患者さんの面倒を見るならば
その人はブッダ自身の面倒を見ていることと同じですよと
だからブッダっていうのは存在の中で最高な存在なんです
そのブッダに手を合わせたとしてもすごい徳があると仏教の信者さん
仏教では言ってるんです
手を合わせただけでもすごい徳が積めますよと
手を合わすどころじゃなくて
お釈迦様の身の回りの面倒を見てあげるならば
それは大変な徳なんですね
でもいないんだからできないんです
それだったらお釈迦様が言うのは
どこらへん
どこでもいるんだから
誰か病気の人々の面倒見なさいと
それは私に対する行為と同じですよと言ってるんです
yo maṃ upaṭṭhaheyya so
gilānaṃ upaṭṭhaheyya という言葉でお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
嘘じゃないんです
ですから
仏教から見れば
治療の世界
薬の世界
病気 病人を助けてあげることっていうのは素晴らしい行為
それはそれまでで
だからといって人が死ぬまで薬を発達しちゃうと
まあ考えた方がいいんですね
例えば今
薬飲みすぎて飲みすぎて薬の効き目がない
薬がありすぎて
お医者さんさえわからないんですね
どんな組み合わせがいいかと
たまに あ
この病気にはこれ飲みなさい
これだったらこれを飲みなさい
これではこれを飲みなさい
だから 12種類ぐらいもらうんですね
もらったものをお互いに薬を合わせてみると
毒になる場合もあるし
人が死ぬ場合もあるし
あるいは全く効き目が無効になる場合もあるし
例えばある薬がきついと言ったら
じゃあこの薬も飲みなさいと一緒に
そうすると
あの薬のきつさがなくなっちゃいます
そしたら
あの薬の効き目も一緒になくなるんです
ものの法則というのはそういう法則ですから
ですから
やり過ぎなんですね
このやり過ぎは不善なんです
で 私たちにしても
私たちは健康的に生きていきたい
それは問題ないです
健康的に生きているためには
いろんなことをする
運動もする
バランスを整えている
食べ物を食べるとよく寝ると
いろんなことをする
それで社会を見ると
これまたやり過ぎなんですね
健康のために健康食品というと
もうあるわあるわあるわ
もうもう
どうかわからないんですね
だから一番いい判断は何一つ使わないこと
それぐらいあるんです
どちらがいいかわからない
そこで健康に運動しようと思ったら
また運動の方法はあるわあるわ
そこで人々も欲張って欲張ってもう運動する
もう一生それにかかってしまうんですね
他の仕事をする暇もなくなるまで
持ってるお金は全部それに行っちゃって
他のことにはもうお金がなくなっちゃうんですね
その中でいろんな怪しい商売やら人騙しやらよくあるんです
できれば
何といいますか
アメリカの商品売ってる番組なんかいろいろあるんですね
で 日本でも放送するし
衛星として放送する場合もあるし
見てください
ほんのくだらない何か道具使って
これこそすごいや抜群だ
これ 1台さえあればもう何のこともないんだとか
言うわ言うわ言うわ
本当にそうなのかと
そこまではやりすぎなんです
ですから
そこまでやるんだから善行為にはならないんですね
残念ですけど
だから仏教から言うならば
人間にはこういう結論なんですね
何の無理もなく
いいことをすることをできるんです
何のことなく
もう自然のことをもうちょっとだけ自分に必要な分だけ回転させて
もう発展させて
自分の体も適当にほどほどもって健康を守って
ほどほどに家族の面倒を見て
ほどほどに仕事をして
もう明るく楽しく生きていれば
それ自体も仏教では徳だと善行為だと言ってるんです
それなのに全部むちゃくちゃなんですね
生きていることは罪
そんなものになってるんですね
それでだいたいちょっと余計な話なんですけど
仏教の話とか何とか言っちゃったら
まあみんな聞きたがらないんですよ
普通だったら皆様はなんかおかしいと思いますけどね
そんなに真剣に聞いてるんだから
大体は聞きたがらないんです
まあうるさい
いろんなことを言ってるんだと
あれやってはいけない
これやってはいけないと言ってるんだと
それで 特に我々の仏教については
上座仏教というか
初期仏教についてはもう悪口言われるは言われるはもう知らないにも関わらず
日本のいろいろ宗教の講義やら放送やら見ると
もうなんか一言こちらに言って終わっちゃうんですね
かなり人気のある有名なこの仏教の講義やったり
文章を書いたりする人がいるんだけど
名前は申し上げませんけど
まあまあ学者ですけどね
それは一般人向けにタレントみたいに仏教の話をしてるんですね
それにはペンネーム使っていて
彼には何の関係もないんだけど
釈尊の教えには言いたい放題悪口を言うんですね
初期仏教には言いたい放題悪口を言うんですね
それで偉そうに私はもう大乗仏教は好だと
法華経の教えなんかすごく好きですよと
言いたい放題のことを言って
なんであんなに腹が立ってるかというと
あの学者さんも肩書きだけ学者ですけど
まあ生まれつきもう何も持ってないんですね
脳細胞っていうのは
だから日本っていうのは勉強しやすい国でしょ
あまりにも教育システムがもうあんまりにも上手にできちゃって
どんなバカにでもできるんですよ
大学卒業ぐらいは
それぐらい驚くほどこの教育制度っていうのはもう発展しているんです
あれは人間のわがまま通りに
寝ていても
まあ教えたものは理解できるようにありとあらゆる工夫して教えてくれるんだから
だから能力ある人
ない人 みんなもう勉強しちゃう
あれももう考えれば
まあそれも話したいんだけどね
ちょっと迷惑といえば迷惑なんですね
だから迷惑だから
それも不善になっちゃいますよ
なぜならば
教育は仏教では素晴らしい善行だと言ってるんです
教育 教えること
だからといって
余計な連中にも余計なことまで教えちゃったら
社会に対してはすごい迷惑でしょうに
なんで我々はいろんな酷い目にあってますかというと
そういう頭の悪い人々に知識が入ったからでしょうに
科学勉強する
科学だけ勉強して何を作るかというと
もう機関銃やら核兵器やら
それを作る
作ったらこれまたあまりノウハウなくても安いお金で作られるんですよ
拳銃とか
それいっぱい作るんですね
作ったものは売らなくちゃいけない
そこでいろんな工夫して売る
お互いに殺すことになっちゃう
もうもうなんかね
拳銃なんか買っても
それはもうおしゃれでどこかに置物に使う必要ないんだから
それだったらお人形とかね
日本人形とかもっと綺麗なものはありますから
やっぱり誰かを撃たなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから そういうふうに世界が恐ろしくなっているのは
知識は素晴らしいものですが
やたらにそれは広げるからなんです
だからインド文化だったらやたらに広げない
やたらに教えない
教えることは最高たる道徳だよと言いながらも
あなたにはちょっと教えたくないんですよと言うんです
いわゆる人のためになることを考えているんです
いつでも
それはそれであの方のお話に戻りますけど
なんであれほど仏教に釈尊の教えに悪口言いますかというと
よく誤解しているんですね
仏教っていうのは
あれやるな
これやるな
これそういうことばっかり言ってるんだと
戒律ばっかり言ってるんだと
あれすごいえらい誤解なんです
じゃあ皆様もずっと私の話を聞いていらっしゃったでしょうに
そんな話言ったんですか？
私はずっと厳密に初期経典に基づいて喋ってるんで
今でも頭の中でぐるぐる回ってるんで
僕はどこら辺のことから喋ってるんですかと
あれやるな
これやるなと言ってるんですか？
僕は　歩くときはこう歩け
喋るときはこう喋れと
ご飯食べる時はこうしなさいと
服はこんな色にしなさいとか
たまにいろいろ冗談言ったりするんだけど
それはただの意見であって
こうしなさいと
こうするなかれと
その 2つだけは言ってないはずなんです
それなのにまあ文句言われるんだから
それだったら僕はもうちょっと怒って
学者ですから
インド文学の専門家だから
テキストくらい読めばどうですかと
だから本当のところは
もう一流のインド文学学者で
テキストも読んでないということなんです
だからテキストを読まなくても博士になるんだからね
その教育制度では
まあまあ
それはそれで
仏教では別にそれやれ
それやるなとか
そんなもうややこしいことは言わないんです
そんなに判断ないんです
この世の中で
そうじゃなくて
必要なのは高度な理解なんです
そこである人が釈尊にこう聞くんです
在家の人が
私たちにとっては
もうこんなお釈迦様おっしゃっているように
出家とかね
すごい瞑想して煩悩をなくして解脱を得るとかね
そんなことはまあちょっとあのお釈迦さん
そんなことはちょっと無理ですよと
奥さんもいるし
子供たちもいるし
やっぱりその連中の面倒を見たいんだと
奥さんのことをすごく好きで
捨てることはできないんだと
あの
それでも地獄には落ちたくないんだと
出家もしたくないし
修行もしたくないし
普通の欲の世界で生きていきたいんですね
でも地獄には落ちたくないんだと
だからどうすれば天国に生まれ変われますかと聞くんですね
聞いたら
あんたちょっと欲張りではないかと
そうはおっしゃってないんです
お釈迦様が
はい わかりましたと
こう言うんです
人は法に従って正しく仕事をして
正しいく収入を得て
それで自分の奥さんやら子供たちやらね
ちゃんと食べさせて育ててあげて
家族をちゃんと円満に面倒を見ていて
死ねば確実に天国に行きますよ
ただそれだけ
ということは
特別に何か行をやりなさいと
朝早く起きて沐浴して
なんとか何とかお祈りしなさいとか
あるいはこれするなかれ
あれするなかれとかね
そういうものは言ってないんです
人間として成功するならば
いわゆる家族は円満で
仕事はちゃんと無事で
子供たちがちゃんと育てられて
社会から批判されないように立派な人だと褒められるような生き方をして
ああ いい人でしたなという言葉をいただいて
死ぬならば天国に行きますよと言っているんだから
ですから
お釈迦様はそんなにうるさくああしなさい
こうするなかれとはおっしゃってないんです
だから本当にこの知恵さえあれば
人間が立派になるのはいとも簡単なんです
仏教では家を捨てろ
財産を捨てろ
社会の発展をやめなさいと一度も言ったことはない
人はどうせ死ぬんだから
健康なんかはまあおろそかにしなさいと
どうせ死ぬんだから
まあそんな余計な面倒くさいんだからと
そんなことは言ってないんです
ジャイナ教みたいにとことん体をいじめなさいとか断食しなさいとか
一回さえ言ってないんです
そんなものをお釈迦様は悪口言ってるんです
苦行をさせてるんだと
人は痛みは嫌いでしょうにと
そういう教えなんです
ですから
この発展論からいきますけど
発展という立場から見ると
社会を発展させて
環境を発展させて
自分の体のことも発展しながら生きることも善行為なんです
特別にお数珠を持ってなんとかなんとか何とかとか言わなくても
別に構いません
楽だと思いますよ
仏教はちゃんと理解すると
そこでなんで不善になるんですかね
なんで我々は家族あって
家族のために頑張って
それ地獄に落ちちゃうんですかね
そこをやりすぎだからなんです
なんで科学発展によって
それは地獄に落ちるか落ちないかは別の話で
説明しやすく私はそう言うんだけど
なんで科学発展で人は地獄に落ちますかというと
やりすぎだからなんですね
そこでその人々はこの基本的なことを忘れているんです
基本的なことは何ですか？
人間の成長
発展こそ大事である
そのために必要なところだけやりなさいと
発展だけ独立させるなと
いつでもそこに人間がいるんだということを忘れるなと
例えば皆様方は仕事をするでしょう
知らないうちに仕事は独立するんですね
一人歩くんですね
これは日本には確実にある現象なんです
仕事は一人歩きする
子供が病気になって倒れて
奥さんには一人の手ではもうなかなか追えないと
だって全く無視
仕事に行かなくちゃって言っちゃうんでしょうね
あれはどうなの？
罪なんです
奥さんに一人でもうなかなか手に負えないほど大変な状態になったところで
何の関係もなく会社に行かなかったら大変だとかね
それを考えて仕事に行くならば
その日は1秒ずつ1秒その人は罪を犯してるんです
なぜならば
仕事が独立して一人歩きしているんです
そこで忘れているのは
何のためにそのアホな人が仕事をしているんですかということなんです
その人は仕事をしているのは自分の幸福のため
会社じゃなくて家族の幸福のためなんですね
そこに生きている人間がいるんですね
その生きている人間の幸福のためなんですね
会社のためじゃないんです
会社にとっては人間というのは単なる道具であって
いらない場合はポイとゴミ箱に捨てるんだから
いくら会社のために頑張ったとしても
追い出されるでしょうに
ちょっと会社のプロフィットが少なくなっちゃうと誰でもリストラになっちゃうし
いくら頑張っても
いくら会社のために尽くしたとしても
例えば会社のために仕事をしようと思って
自分の子供が死んじゃったと
会社にはプロフィットが少なくなっちゃうと
収入が減ると自分がクビになる羽目になっちゃったら
それ言ってみてください
泣きながら
私は会社のために一生懸命頑張りましたと
子供は病気になって死にかけていたのに
僕は会社に来ましたと
それで子供は死んじゃったと
奥さんは離婚しましたと
そこまで私は会社のために頑張ったんだと言ったっても
クビはクビなんです
ああ そうですか
あなたは素晴らしいんだと
じゃあ仕事してください
言わない
会社に必要なのは会社をよく儲けてくれる人なんです
儲けさせてくれる人なんです
ですから
なんで人間そんなことをするかと
仏教から見れば
仕事をすることは善行為で
仕事をしない怠け者たちが毎日罪を犯してるんです
だからまあたまに私は言いますけど
この仕事もあまりしないで
じゃあ瞑想でもしたいと
僕はあんまりいい顔をしないんです
いわゆる基本的にしなくちゃいけない
道徳さえしない人が
どうやって高いレベルに頑張ることできるんですかと
ですから
仕事をするのは当たり前であって
自分食べる分はなんとか自分でいくらか努力しなくちゃいけないんですね
それだから
それは道徳だから
じゃあ仕事一本でいきますよと言ったら
もう罪なんです
よく覚えておいてください
仕事をするのは善行為で
仕事をしたら
その人は真面目に仕事をしたら
ただそれだけででも死んじゃったら天国に行くんです
でも 仕事を独立させちゃって
仕事のために
会社のためにと思っちゃったら
もう不善行為で地獄に落ちる可能性あるんです
やりすぎなんです
それを知恵で考えてほしい
知識で考えてほしい
どこまで善か
どこをどういわゆる
何といいますか
あの　メーターに赤いなんとかありますね
この赤い線を飛んではいけないんです
車にもありますね
スピードメーターにこの赤いところが
そこまで車スピード出す必要はないんですね
そうすると必ず死ぬんだから
そのそれなんですよ
機械のメーターと同じなんです
どんな機械にもではなくて
いろんな機械にはメーターがついていて
メーターには必ず赤い部分があるんです
あまりにも危険な機械だったら
この赤い部分だけじゃなくて
そこに固定している針もあるんです
もうしっかりしなさいと
この固定している針に動いている針が来ちゃったら気をつけろと
それ飛んじゃったらもう危ないんだと
我々がよく使ってる電車のブレーキでもそうでしょ
空気圧でやってますから
どれぐらい空気圧あった方がいいかって決まってるんです
それ上へ針が行っちゃったら
さっさとこの余分のところは外へ出さなくちゃいけないんです
そうでないともう大勢の人の命はどうかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから
仕事をするのは素晴らしいことで
善行為で赤いメーターの赤いところに行っちゃったらもう残念で
我々の社会はこの赤いところまで行くのは自慢にしているんですね
仕事を一本で一筋で独立させて目的を忘れてやるのは自慢にするんです
お医者さんたちも
医学の分野も
自分の研究だけどこまででも発展することこそ自慢にする
それだったら残念ながら不善行為になる
話は随分長くなりましたけど
同じテーマで
あの
ポイント一つしか言わなかったんですね
人間の成長が道徳であると
成長のためになるものは道徳であると
そこで物質的な成長のことしか今まで言わなかったんだけど
話をもう半分言っちゃったんだけど
時間としては
そこで我々にわかることは
同じ行為
同じ行動があるところまでいい
善　善因だから善果が得られる
あるところまで行って
それ以上行っちゃったら
不善行為
不善行為で悪因だから悪果が出てくる
悪い結果が出てくる
そういう教えですから
お釈迦様はやたらに人にあれやるな
これやるなと言っているんだと誤解する必要はないんです
あれは勉強していないからなんです
テキストを読んでないからなんです
丁寧にテキストを読むと
ちゃんとお釈迦様はそういうことをおっしゃっていることがわかるはずなんです
ですから
例えばお釈迦様の時代で言ったら
独裁的な王権ですか
王様が国を支配していて
民主主義の立場から見ればとんでもない政府なんですね
王に支配されて
王の好き勝手に国民を支配されているのは
それは民主主義という立場から見るときなんですね
お釈迦様は王様たちがもうとんでもないんだと言っちゃったら
お釈迦様さえ命さえどうなるかわかりませんから
それはそれで
お釈迦様が王様たちに言うのは
国を守ることは素晴らしいことであって
国民のことを大事に考えるのは素晴らしいことであって
王様は法律にのっとって正しく判断して行動することは素晴らしいことであって
それを犯しちゃったら
もうドーンと地獄ですよと
ですから
王様に自分の仕事をして天国に行くか地獄に落ちるかだと
どっちでも決められるんです
例えば 王様には人を殺す権利があったんです
そこで悪いことをした人々
犯罪を起こした人々は連れてくる
今日疲れたんだからと
今日ちょっと遊びたいんだと言って
今日何人来たんですか？
と　王様は
10人今日犯罪者がいるんだ
じゃあみんな死刑
私は帰りますと
とはできますよ
気分次第に
打ち首と言って玉座を立って帰ればそれで終わりますから
もうそれは法律で
でもそんなことをやっちゃったら
王が自分が法に従って政治をやったことにはならないんですね
そこでちゃんと人の話を聞いて
この人は鞭で打つか
打ち首にするか
どっちかと判断した方がいいんですね
この人を殺しちゃっても何の意味もないんだと
たまにいるんですね
悪いことをするんだけど
本当はしたくない
悪いことをして人の家を破っちゃって見つかっちゃう
泥棒した
やったことはないと
よく話してみると
本人が本当はそんな行為をやりたくない
でも財産は全くない
家族がいるわ
子供がいるわ
自分には住む家がない
住む土地は全くない
商売したいと思っても全然財産がない
農業やろうと思っても全然畑は全くない
あるいはカースト制度があったんだから
カーストで云々と言われて社会から追い出されているとかね
それでやむを得ず盗むしかないんだと
お腹が空くんだから
子供が泣くんだから
ただバカみたく死ぬのが正しいんですかね
私にはお金がない
だからもう死ぬまで待とうと
それも正しいと言えないでしょうに
じゃあ泥棒してでもあなた方にはご飯食べさせますよと思う父親の気持ちはいきなり犯罪者だと決められますかね
そういうケースの場合は
王様はちゃんと考えて
お前本当にもうとんでもない奴だなと
じゃあお金あげますから
土地あげますから
これからしっかり法を守って頑張りなさい
今度間違ったらクビだよと
打ち首だよと言われて帰したとしてもいいんじゃないんですか
ですから
善悪判断というのはそういうふうに見てほしいんです
ただ盗んだんだから泥棒じゃないんです
その人はなんでそんなことをしたんですかと
そこら辺も考えていなくちゃいけない
今のケースはもう僕は強引に作ったケースなんですけど
例えば子供たちが病気になって死にかけているんだと
1週間も食べるもの何もないんだと
泣いてるんだと
自分しかその親戚も誰もいないんだ
助けてあげる人誰もいないんだと
それで我慢できなくて
まあ何か取っていっちゃうんだと
人のものを
そこら辺はもういきなり泥棒やと言ってぶん殴ったりするのは正しいでしょうかと
なぜならば
その人はやっぱりある人々のため
ある人々の命を助けてあげようと
という一部もあるんです
ですから
本当の犯罪人が誰ですかと
なぜこの人が貧しくなったんですかと
そこも探さなくちゃいけない
その人貧しくなったのは自分のせいだったら
まあしょうがない
自分で博打というんですか
そういう賭け事をなんかやったりして
全財産がなくなったのならば
その人のせいであって
社会はその人に幸福で生きていられないようないじめやらいろんな差別やらしたならば
その泥棒は社会のせいであって個人のせいじゃないんです
そういうふうに判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
やたらにいい加減で
無責任で
これは悪い
これは正しいとかね
思っちゃったら
それも罪なんです
いい加減な判断することも
イエス様も結構仏教的なことをおっしゃいましたから
イエス様は厳しく禁止されているんですね
人を判断するなと
どんなわけがあっても
人間にはそれはダメですよと
それぐらい言ってるっていうことは
人間にはそんなに簡単に善悪判断できないからなんですね
でも仏教ではそんなこと言わない
まあ難しいということは認めていますけど
知恵を持ちなさいと
知恵で物事を考えろと
そうすると判断できるんだよと
しっかりと
次の心の発展というところをちょっとお話ししますけど
また繰り返し申し上げますけど
人は成長するべき
精神的に物質的に
それは仏教の立場です
成長する方向は善であると
そこでなんでインドやら仏教の国々はそんなに経済的に先進国になってないかというと
その今言った話なんですね
やたらに金持ちになろうとは思ってないんです
お金がもう余計に入っちゃうと
すぐお布施してしまうんです
だからお金がないんです
もし農作物なんかドーンとたくさん出来ちゃったら
天気が良くて余分なものは全部もうお布施しちゃう
そういうことで
アメリカみたいな
ヨーロッパみたいな日本みたいに無茶金持ちな国にはならないんですね
それはまあ
ヨーロッパ的な思想を持ってる方々は
あの連中はバカだよと言うならば
それはもうしょうがないかもしれませんけど
ずっと貧しいんだよと
だから 必死になって無茶になって無知になっても
むちゃくちゃ発展しちゃうと
結局自己破壊なんですね
ですから
貧しい国々よりは豊かな国々の場合は人間が苦しんでいるんです
事実は孤独で
精神的な問題いっぱいあって
自信がなくて
笑えなくて
笑うためにお金使う国ってあるんですね
この世の中で
これは先進国でしょうに
笑うためにすごいお金使う
笑い商売やるんだから笑えばいいのに
別に　なんで笑えないんですかね
笑えないほど心は痛めてるんです
子供さえ遊べないんだから
もう戦争しているんですね
教育 教育
教育と　競争
競争 競争と
だから発展どころか
自分たちが自分で作った地獄で生きてるんです
そこで大きな綺麗な建物を見て
綺麗な道路を見て
綺麗な車やらそんなものを見て
すごい高価な
10万  20万円の値打ちのある服を見て
俺たちが本当に幸福だと
すごく自慢までしてるんですね
それはね
ちょっと変な鏡で自分を見ていることと同じなんですね
変な鏡で自分を見ると
変に見えちゃうんですね
例えば背が高くない人が鏡あるんですよ
その鏡の前に立っちゃったら
すごい背が伸びて見えるんです
ちょっとカーブなんか入れたらもう伸びて見える
だからそんな風に鏡の前に立って
あ 私って本当に背が高くていいなとか
自慢したとしても
それはまあちょっとおかしい自慢だけで
幸福だ幸福だと自慢してるだけで
心はものすごく痛んで悩んでるんだから
そこまでする必要ありますかと
ということは仏教の疑問なんですね
そういうことで
あまりにもやたらに無意味な自己破壊になる発展は不善であると
と覚えておいてください
それからそれにつけて言いますけど
いかなる毒でも作ることは
どんなお金になっても
それは良くない
完全に悪いんです
毒を作ること
武器を作ること
決して必要じゃないんです
武器を作るから
人は互いに喧嘩しているんです
戦争があるんだから
平和のために
国を守るために
軍隊っていうのはとんでもない嘘
誤解なんです
すごい強い軍事力があると
自分の国の平和が危ないんです
ない場合は戦争しませんから
落ち着いてるんだから
人と仲良くするんだから
隣の国々と
いくらかの軍隊っていうのは必要かもしれません
どうせ人間というのは怒ったりするわ
法律を犯したりするわ
いろんなことをやったりするわ
ですから
それなりの国の中のいくらかの平和を守るためのいくらか管理職は必要かもしれませんけど
巨大な軍事力っていうのは何のためですかね
ああいうのは仏教からはもう完全に罪だと
言ってるんですね
あれは発展じゃないんです
殺すことを発展とは言わないんだから
そこら辺で物質的な豊かさのことをやめまして
で また心の発展ということ
心が発展するならば
その行為も善行為なんです
そこで一番大事なのは心の発展
命の発展
体の発展ではないんです
体は道具だと見てるんですね
例えば目がある
目で美しいものを見て心が喜ぶ
目は道具なんですね
目がなくなっちゃったら
美しいものは見られません
見られない
耳が道具で耳があるんだから
綺麗な音が聞こえる
楽しい　その道具なくなっちゃったら音が聞こえなくなっちゃう
ですから
目と耳よりは心の方が優先にしなくちゃいけないんですね
心こそ成長するならば
それこそ正しい成長ですということになってしまって
物質的な豊かさより心の豊かさ
豊かさが優先にする
その点になっちゃうと
仏教は違うことを言うんですね
もし物質的な豊かさが心の豊かさに妨げになるならば
物質的な豊かさはやめなさいと
わかりますかね
心の発展に
進歩に成長に物質的な豊かさがダメになってるんだと
いわゆる妨げになっているんだと
それだったら何のことなく物質的なことをやめなさいと
やめて心の方を成長しなさいと
そちらの方が優先ですから
究極的にこの出家現象があるのはそういうわけなんですね
決して家族があって悪いわけじゃないんです
家族があるお子さんがいることはもう罪じゃないんです
でもそれやっちゃうと
そこで日が暮れるんですよ
家族の面倒を見ることだけで
子供の面倒を見ることだけで
心の余裕
豊かさ 心を育てることにはなかなか時間がなくなっちゃうんですね
それだったら物質的な世界にさようならという
それは決して罪ではないんです
それまた善行為なんです
いわゆる優先しているのは心の豊かさ
なぜならば
死んだら体は持っていかない
死後の世界を信じていてもなくても
それは関係ないし
あってもなくても構いませんけど
死んだら体は持っていかないということだけは我々は知ってるんですね
体は持っていけないし
借金して作った家も持っていかない
会社は持っていかない
全部置いておく
銀行の預金もそのまま
それは他の人のものになっちゃう
もし死後もあって何か持っていくならば
自分の心ですね
持っていくのは
ですから
それを育てた方が一番正しいと
で 心を育てることをより正しいと言って
心を育てるっていうのは
心　我々のこの成長を妨げている心のものはまず直しちゃう
わかりやすく言えば
怒りやら欲やら嫉妬やら
そういうふうな心の醜い部分
自分でも見たくない自分の心のところ
それを直す
自分で自慢できる心を作る
もうすごい簡単で
その言葉が
それで覚えておきましょう
私は私に自慢できる心を作りましょうと
皆様は皆様の心について自慢できるならば
心というのは頭じゃないんです
で もうそれで素晴らしいんです
例えば
例えばじゃなくて
その場合でも
また悪いことが出てきたりする場合があるんです
この心を豊かにしようと心を育てようと思っていろんなことをする
その時でも
この　何て言いますか
赤いところを飛んではいけないんです
そちらもあるんです
メーターの赤いところは
これ以上は赤いんだと
まあわかりやすく言えばこういうこと
例えばすごく食欲があって
食欲じゃなくて
ものすごい食べ物に執着しているんだと
食べること食べること
他のことは頭に何もないんだと
その人はやっぱりこんな食べ過ぎて食べるばっかりで
自分がなんか情けないんだと
欲を何とかしたいんだと
言われたところで
じゃあ断食してみようと思ってとことん断食しちゃうんだと
それ ものすごい食べ過ぎばっかりの人には一番簡単にできる断食
極端だから
そこをやってみて
どんどんやっちゃうと
もう断食ということをやってますけど
なかなかあの欲だけは消えないんですね
さらに欲が強烈になる場合あるんです
で この断食をやっている場合はよくあることで
この断食終わったすぐ食べるは食べるは食べるという
食べてまた元に戻るか
さらにもっと病気になるという
ケースがもう随分あるんです
10人断食したら
断食によって心落ち着いてる
落ち着くという人はまあ二人ぐらいないほどなんです
8人もやっぱり嫌々でいら立ちして
もう食べたくて食べたくて
いつ終わるかいつ終わるかと我慢して
で 終わっちゃったらまた思う存分食べてしまうということもありますね
そういうふうに断食は一概に悪いんじゃなくて
断食するならば
それによって自分の心にある
この貪って食べたくなる心が直して成長するか
それをチェックしなくちゃいけない
荒行も悪くないんです
もし荒行をやることによって
自分の怠け癖がなくなっちゃって
元気になって
清々しい気持ちになるんだと
というならば
その分だけまあいいかも
でも 荒行よくやりましたとか
自分が　あれすごくできますよと思って自慢して
荒行の何でしたっけ？
専門家になっちゃって
それで自分のアイデンティティ作っちゃって
もう認めて欲しがっちゃうでしょ
それでどうですか？
余計な高慢
余計な自慢
自分がすごく偉いんだと
という考え方は入ってしまうんですね
荒行なんかできない僕のような人を見ると
なんで情けない怠け者だとかね
人をけなしてみたりとかね
軽視したりするとか
そういうことまで心は変化しちゃう
そうすると荒行は罪であって
不善であって
善行にならない
だから心清らかにするいろんな方法も
気をつけて
これでどこまでいいか
どこで止まるべきかと理解してやらなくちゃいけない
そうでないと
これ正しいということは言えないんです
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想にしても
人に自慢して比べて
私はもう 3時間瞑想してやると
4時間瞑想してやると
やって足がもう故障したりとかね
そういうことになっちゃったら
それはもう良くない
不善なんです
3時間座って瞑想するか
1時間座って瞑想するかということはポイントではなくて
心が落ち着いたか
成長しましたか？
しっかりできたかと
何か結果があるかっていうことがポイントなんです
そういうふうに心を成長することも気をつけてやってほしい
いわゆる方法としては
これという方法はないんです
テーマ一つなんですけど
だいたい善悪判断というのは
基本的に言えば
これぐらいで理解していただければ結構だと思いますよ
そこでいくらかの
結論ですか
いくらかの結論的なことを申し上げますけど
私たちはやっぱりやたらに物事を判断しない方がいいんです
心の中から世の中を見て
あれはいけない
これはいけない
これはけしからんとかね
そういうふうに暗い目で見る必要もないし
あれはすごい
これはすごいというバカバカなバカらしい目で物事を見る必要もないんです
そんな知るわけじゃないんです
これ どっちでもよくあることなんですよ
もう我々の社会では
ちょっと人が何か悪いことを何かしたと思ったら
その人はその村からも出て行かなくちゃいけないんです
家族まで親戚まで
それぐらい批判するんですね
社会が　あれ恐ろしいんです
醜いんです
そこでどこかで誰かが何か言ってるんだとか
誰かに超能力あるんだとか
誰か人の病気治したんだと聞いたところで
みんなサーッとそこに入っちゃって
もう何十万人でも入っちゃって
もういろんなことをやって
またあとで騙された騙されたと
また泣いたりする
これどっちでも良くないんです
そんな判断できるわけじゃないんです
すぐあれけしからん
これいけないと思う人は暗いし
あれはすごい
これはすごい
あれはものすごい珍しい
これ聞いてびっくりしました
すごいことだと思う人はもう無知であるし
自信がない弱いものなんです
すぐ引かれますから
どっちでも良くない
もっと落ち着いて
判断する
評価する
判断というよりは
具体的な例を出しちゃうと
講義としてはちょっとあまり良くないんだけど
2年  3年前もサイババ現象ということで全国的にまあわいわいとやってるんですね
本は出るわテレビで番組出るわ
ずっと団体行くわ行くわ
必死で
すごいすごい神様だ
神様だ あれこそ神様だと
またある日
もういいわ
あれもう今はあまり人気ないとかね
なんでそんなにバカですかね
なんであんなにすぐ飛び込むんですかね
なんですぐ諦めるんですかね
私はすぐ飛び込むことは良くないと
ともう　すぐ
飛び込むからすぐ諦める
ゆっくりと客観的に物事を判断して
そこに行ってもあんまり夢中になって
これこそだこれこそだではなくて
ほどほどに見て
何かいいことがあるならばいい結果を得て
悪いところがあるならばそれは置いといて自分を守ればいいのに
別にサイババのところに走るのは悪いことじゃないし
他の宗教に走ることは別に悪いことじゃないし
私のやり方が悪いだけなんです
もしいいことをおっしゃっているならば
あ これはいい教えだと
そこだけ見ておかしいことを言うならば
そこら辺はおかしいんだと
すごいクールな心で理解すると
何の問題もないんです
社会現象は起こることはないんです
ですから
結局私たちには全く善悪の判断能力はついてないんだから
いつでも落とし穴に落ちるばっかりなんですね
あ こちらで落ちた落とし穴だ
怪我しましたと
やっと立ったところで次の落とし穴に落ちちゃうんですね
それから立ち上がったら次に落ちちゃうんですね
落とし穴がなければなんかもう気が済まないぐらいで
それで人生は苦しくなってしまうんですね
落とし穴だらけですけど
こうこうやってあっちこっちグニャグニャと私たちは前へ進まなくちゃいけないんです
こういうふうにしていただいた方が
仏教の道徳的な世界なんですね
いわゆる心の成長と
ある程度の物質的な成長と徹底的な心の成長ということを目指して努力すればいいと
これやるな
あれやるなということは言ってないんです
仏教では
例えば我々比丘たちに
お釈迦様は何億ぐらいかな
もうものすごい数のしきたり
戒律などなど決まってるんです
厚いテキスト五冊なんです
お坊さんたちの生き方
きめ細かく
もう設定されて設定されて
戒律だけ勉強すると一生かかるほどすごい量なんです
それぐらいあって
結局お釈迦様はそういう項目決めたくなかったんです
もともとは
で こういう話なんですね
サーリプッタ尊者が
ある日 お釈迦様にこう聞くんです
どんな風にすればこの教えは長持ちするんですかと
長く人間の中で生き延びます
生き延びますかと聞かれると
お釈迦様はこう言うんですね
ちゃんと生き方のいわゆるこれはするなかれ
こういうことをしなさいという戒律ですか
それはきちんと設定して決まっておけば
教えはもう長生きするだろうと
と言ったんです
それはどういうことかというと
皆様も瞑想についても
他のことについても
ちゃんとしたテキストマニュアルがあったら
最初の
１日はこうやりなさい
2 日目はこうやりなさい
1 週間目はこうやりなさい
こうするとこうなりますと
そこで最後の
1ヶ月
4 週間目でこうしなさいと
それであなたの修行は終わり
あなたは悟っているんだと
そういうふうにマニュアルなんか作っちゃったら
すごい元気でみんな実践するんです
そうすると他の人にも教えるんで
テキストあるんだから
すごい元気に
こういう風に瞑想するんだと
マニュアル文化だから
で 私の話はなかなかちょっと曖昧だと
わからないんだと
しっかり言った方がどうですかとか言われる場合もあります
瞑想にしても
どこまで進んでいるんですかと
まだどこまでやるんですか？
とか はっきり言った方がいいんじゃないかと
テキスト作った方がいいんじゃないかと
そういうシステムがあった方が
人間っていうのはもう守って
それに束縛されてやるんです
どういうことか？自分で判断できないからなんです
右に曲がれと言ったら右に曲がるのは簡単であって
十字路か十字道路に来て
どちらの方が道かなと自分で判断するのはなかなか難しいんです
右か左かまっすぐかと
そこで右だと矢印やっちゃったら平気で
じゃあ右に行こうと
もし正しい道が右であるならば正しいんでしょうし
矢印が間違っていると間違っちゃいますけど
それだったらやっちゃうんです
ですから
お釈迦様は同じことを言ったんです
きちんと決まりを決めておいておけば
仏教は長持ちしますよと言われたら
サーリプッタ尊者が
それだったらお願いいたしますと
我々にちゃんとしきたり戒律を設定して教えてくださいと
ちゃんとしたシステムを
言ったら
お釈迦様は何を言ったんですか？
待ちなさい
ちょっと待ちなさいと
もしそういうことが必要であるならば
その時は私が決めますと
あなたは困る必要はないんだと
あの偉大なる知恵のサーリプッタ尊者にもそう言われたんです
ということは
お釈迦様はこうしなさい
こうするなかれという方法では教えたくなかったということ
お分かりでしょう
それでもお坊さんたちが間違いを起こすようになっちゃったんですね
頭の悪い人々が
まあやってはいけないと言ってないし
まあいいんじゃないかと
っていろんな間違いを起こしちゃったんです
それはそのお坊さんたちが悪いんです
なぜならば
道徳判断
お釈迦様は最初から教えてあったんだから
悟るために出家したならば
悟ることの妨げになることはやってはいけない
当たり前のことなんですね
そんなことは言わなくたって
それすぐ忘れちゃった
自分の目的を
あるお坊さんがこのある祭りがあって
そこら辺に托鉢に行ったんです
そしたらみんないっぱい酒飲んでお祭りやってるんですね
そこで人々はいいところに来ていただきまして
ありがとう
どうぞどうぞいらっしゃいと
で みんなもう祭りやってますから
まあいかがですかと
で 酒をあげたんです
お坊さんもまあお布施もらったものだから
まあいっぱい飲んで酔っ払ってお寺に帰っちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様はすごく厳しく叱って
何者かと
この人は
あんまりもう酔っ払ってもう倒れて
お坊さんたちはもう大体出家は酒飲まないんだから
それをお釈迦様のところに連れて行ったんですね
捕まえて連れて行って
お釈迦様の方に頭を入れてもう寝かせておいたんです
寝かしたら
この人酔っ払ってるから
またぐるぐる立ち回って回っちゃって
釈尊の方に足を出して
外の方に
玄関の方に頭を出して
もうまた寝返っているんですね
またお坊さん
こんな失礼なことをと言って
また直しちゃうんです
直してもまた頑固で
また嫌と逆の方にお釈迦様の方には足
尊い方の方に足を入れて
向こうでは座ったり寝たりはしないんです
だからお釈迦様もこの人は何者かと
もう酔っ払ってるから
何言ったってわからない
そこで比丘たちに聞いたんですね
この人はこんな態度は前も取ったことはありますかと
前もこういう風に失礼な行儀の悪い
常識のない態度を取ったことがありますか？
と言えば
いいえ そんなことは今まで一度もなかったんですよと
それだけの答えで
じゃあ何ですかと
今日はと
今日は祭りだからもう酔っ払ってるんだからと
ですから
今日限りで一滴の酒もするな
口にするなと
そしたら戒律違反だよと戒律を設定する
そこであのお坊さんが自分の目的を忘れちゃったし
それで設定することになったんです
そういうふうに戒律ができてできて
これ 1億も飛んじゃって
3億も飛んじゃって
数は　 4億
5億ぐらいあるんだそうです
私は数えたことがないんだけど
そんな覚えられますかね
それでもお釈迦様は亡くなる時も自分の気持ちを表して亡くなったんです
私は亡くなってから
こんなややこしいきめ細かい戒律をね
もう置いといてもいいんですよと
きめ細かい
もううるさいとことかに置いといてもいいんですよと
ですから
やっぱりお釈迦様の偉大なる姿勢というか
真理に徹底的に従っていた
あの姿はよく見えるんです
だからといってお坊さんたちが戒律をやめましょうとは決めてないんです
せっかく偉大なる先生に決められたものだから
一生懸命守りましょうと
それは大乗仏教文化になって
まあ片っ端から破ろうと思ってもう
戒律一つも守ってない状態になっているんですけど
破っちゃったら全部破れてしまいますよと
上座仏教は決めたんですね
ですから守りましょうと
で 他の自由な考え方あった人は
まあ面倒くさいことはやめましょうと
そこで人間に判断できないんだから
面倒くさいことをやめましょうというのはいいんですよ
面倒くさい戒律をやめても
そこで何をやめるかというと
自分の欲に従ってやりたいことがあるんですね
例えば酒を飲みたいとか
結婚したいとか
金持ちになりたいとか
ごく普通の欲はあるでしょうに
それを抑えるために修行しているんだけど
そういう戒律を破っちゃったんですね
破って この仏教から追い出されたグループがまず
1番目にしたのは
財産を持つことなんですね
金を持つこと
それから徐々に酒
このかすかにかすかにアルコール入っているものは飲んでもいいんじゃないかとか
酒は良くないんだと
でもかすかにちょっとアルコール
ほんのかすかにビールぐらいっていうのはもうただの飲み物だからという感じで
まあちょっとちょっと緩めちゃうんですね
あの緩め方は間違ってるんですよ
欲に関係ない戒律を捨ててもよかったのに
むさぼりに怒りに関係ない戒律を
なんとかしてもよかったのに
例えば衣を着る時はきちんとしっかりと決まって衣を着なくちゃいけない
それ 忙しくていろんなことをやったりするし
お寺のいろんな面倒を見たりすると
衣はなんとかちょっとなっても構いません
それから当時では服っていうのはものすごい高価なものだから
必死に大事に守らなくちゃいけない
現代になってくると
嫌になるほどあるし
全然お金かからないし
例えば 1万円ぐらいあれば
私にはすごい品質の一番いい衣っていうのは
3着ぐらい買えるんです
タイなんかでは安いんです
安いだけじゃなくて
まあちょっとあっちこっち一週間、二週間いると
誰かからお布施でもらうこともあるんですね
ですから
そんなに真剣に衣にかすかにでも地面に触れないように丁寧に折っておいたりとか
そこまでやらなくてもいいんです
別に　それは欲に関係ないと私は個人で思っちゃいますけど
でも このいろんなお坊さんたちのやり方を見ると
日本でもね
衣の着る着方によって
こっち結んじゃうでしょ
そこは結び目は前に行くか下に行くか
左にするか右にするか
それすっごいうるさいんです
で いっぱい裂ける
そこでちゃんと合わせたりして
ここをちゃんと合わせて
ここでちゃんと何ミリかとか
そこを決めて
こちら何ミリかとかね
衣を着て
こんな感じで法事なんかに参加する
そこはすごい真剣で
終わっちゃったら酒飲んで飲んで酔っ払って人の悪口言って帰っちゃうんですね
だからおかしいといえばおかしいんですね
やっぱりもう無視してもいいものは
例えば普通のズボンなんかね
まあジーンズでも着てお経をあげて法事やっても
別にどうってことないでしょと思いますけど
ずっと普通の服でいるんだから
それはダメなんです
だからそこでちょっと危なくなったなって
もう仏教はどういうことか分からなくなっちゃったんですね
で いまだに我々の悪口言ってるんで
うるさい仏教だと
嫌ですよと
初期仏教なんか
それはそれで置いといて
必要なのは形式的な
法律みたいな戒律ではなくて
心は育てますか？と
煩悩をなくしますか？と
解脱を得られますか？
ということなんです
そういうことで
仏教ではあまり肉魚食べるなとは言ってないんです
このダイバダッタが比丘は肉魚は食べてはいけません
と戒律を決めたんです
お釈迦様は追い出しちゃったんです
いい加減にしろと
肉魚食べたくない人は食べなくてもいいと
もらって食べたい人は食べてもいいんだ
それは人の自由だよと
なぜならば
お釈迦様から見れば
肉を食べなかったから悟ったという人がありえないことなんです
肉を食べちゃったから
体が病気になったということはあり得るかもしれませんけど
一生肉魚を食べなかった
それで悟りましたという一人もいないんです
それはただの体に物質を入れ替えるだけのことで
それによって体の調子が良くなるか悪くなるかっていうのは別な話で
心は成長するかしないかっていうのはまた別な話で
そこでたまに人は病気になるでしょうに
で 何人かお坊さんがいたんですよ
貧しい村で住んでいて
毎日もう例えばご飯だけもらったりして
おかずはなし
それで食べる生活
それでもう栄養失調で体がもう血液もなくて真っ白くなったりとか
それでいつでもそういう貧血で
もう眠たくて眠たくて
体がだるくて
ヴィパッサナー修行にはすごく力が必要なんです
すごく体力が必要なんです
苦行はないんだけど
心はちゃんとものすごくしっかり見ているんだから
結構エネルギーは取りますよ
それで修行できないんですね
お釈迦様はその人に肉食いなさいとか
魚食いなさいと言わないんです
言わない
その代わりに
あなたはどこに住んでいるんですか？
と場所を聞くんです
場所を聞いて
ああ そうですか
いえ あなたはなんとか何とか村に行って
そこで自分の住む部屋を作って修行しなさいと
それだけ言ったことがあるんです
それで注釈書に書いてあるんです
なんでその村にそのお坊さんを送ったかというと
それは漁師の村で
毎日魚を食べているんですね
そこでお坊さんが托鉢に行ったら
人々は作った料理をくれるから
どうせ魚やらいろんなものをもらうんですね
でもらったものを食べなくちゃいけないでしょ
それを食べると
2 〜3週間でもう元気になっちゃったんです
それで元気になったところで
修行してちゃんと悟ったんです
ですから
そういういい加減な戒律はよくないんです
戒律もやっぱり心は育てるためにある
2時間ぐらいめどにして喋りますから
もうちょうど
2時間ですけど
で そこで仏教でも皆様には
五戒を言ったんですね
その五戒にも文句を言う方々はいますけど
で 五戒と十悪というものはあるんです
それは決まりでで
なんでそういうものは決まりですかと
例えば殺生するなと
で そこでも徹底しているんですね
殺生するためには
怒りがなければ殺せないんです
たとえ魚殺すにしたとしても
怒りでないと殺せないんです
みんなちょっと人殺す場合は怒りですよとわかるんだけど
もう食べるために魚を釣ったりすると
別に怒りじゃないでしょ
あれは楽しくやってるんだからと思い込むでしょ
そうじゃないんです
美味しく食べるために
鶏であろうが
牛であろうが
魚であろうが
さばいて食べている場合は
殺す場合は怒りなんです
なぜかというと
魚を見て
ああ かわいい魚ですねとか思ったら殺せないんです
愛情が生まれたら
やっぱりこんなに立派に育ったんだから
やっぱり元気で悠々と泳いでいてほしいなと
という愛情が生まれたら殺せないんです
ですから
殺すことは怒りであると
心理的には決まっている
怒りは心の堕落であって
成長ではありません
怒りというのはすごい暗いエネルギーなんです
そこでやめましょうと
そこら辺はしっかりと決まっているんです
言い訳を言うなと
こういうわけで殺したらどうですか
と　言い訳を言うなと
どんなわけで殺したとしても怒りですよと
たとえ虫でもアリでも殺すなと
それは心を成長するためなんです
決まりで
人は殺すのは良くない
動物は殺してもいいとか
そういう何とかルールってしちゃったら
もうまた壊れちゃうんですね
そうすると敵を殺してもいいんじゃないか
犯罪者を殺してもいいんじゃないかと
殴ってきた人を殺してもいいんじゃないかとか
またどんどんどんどん膨張する
国のために殺した方がいいんじゃないかと思っちゃったら
もう大量の殺人までしちゃうんですね
ですから
もう絶対的にやめましょうと
同じく盗むことは欲か怒りかどっちかなんですね
その場合は自分にはものはない
それで人のものを取りたくなる
それは欲なんですね
あるいは人は元気で幸福で生きている
それはすごく嫉妬する
じゃあ盗んでやりますと
それは怒りと
ですから
あの人は本当に幸福で幸せで元気で生きていてほしい
だから盗みましょうということはあり得ない話なんですね
国のものを盗む時でも
会社のものを盗む時でも
やはりその会社のためを思って盗んでいるわけじゃないんです
税金ごまかす時でも
国のためを思って私は税金ごまかしているよということにはならないんですね
ですから
盗むなという戒律は成り立つ
そういうふうに戒律は成り立っている
それも五戒ぐらい
十悪もあります
それはまあ決まっていて反論はできないんですね
だいたい仏教の善悪っていうのは
まあそれぐらいのことで
もう一つもポイント一つしか言わなかったんだけど
もう一つのポイントを言います
これも覚えておいてください
我々の行動が貪瞋痴でするならば
いわゆる何か行動する場合は
この心から出てくるエネルギーは
むさぼりか怒りか無知であるならば
もう文句なし
不善なんです
怒り 欲の反対
人を助けること
怒りの反対
慈悲の心
無知の反対
智慧の心
知識の心
それでやるものは何でもかんでも善行為なんです
で 私もそう勘違いして悪口言ったりはするんだけどね
もうすごいきつく悪口言ったら
人間が自分のこの無明の闇を
壁を破ってくれるんじゃないかなと
まあちょっときつい言葉でも
人の悪口でも平気で言ってやろうとたまに言いますけど
もし私の気持ちが正しければ善行為であって
いくら悪口言っても
もし私は怒りでいろんな宗教グループに対して怒りを持っていて
倒したくて悪口を言うならば
それは怒りだから不善行為なんですね
ですから
単なる人を叱ったんだから怒りですよ
罪ですよとは決めてはいけない
人を叱ったのはどんな目的ですかと
その人のことを本当に愛情を持って考えて
悪いことは叱らなきゃやめてくれないんだ
ですからきつく叱ってやると
そうするとこの人はいい人間になるだろうと思ったら
それはいい行為であって
あまりにも悪いことをする
言うことを聞かない
それでぶってしまう
それも怒りではないんです
悪いことをやめてほしいから
でも悪いことをするから
腹が立ってぶっちゃったら
それは不善なんです
親と子の関係のいつでも間違いがあるのはそういうことなんです
親が子供を叱ったり
勉強しなさいと言うんだけど
そこにあるのは親の我
子供に対するすごい執着
それから妄想
子供に対する余計な希望
それに沿わないと母が怒るんです
それで勉強しなさいと
勉強しなかったらダメですよと怒ったりする
それは不善行為で
そういう子供たちが必ず悪くなってしまう
そうじゃなくて
勉強しなかったら不幸になるのはあなたですよと
私は母として私の仕事をやっているだけですよ
あなたを育てることは私の仕事であって
善悪を教えてあげることは私の仕事であって
そういうふうな無執着の心があって
勉強しろと言ったらちゃんと勉強してくれる
ですから
この行動で判断するんじゃなくて
心で判断しようと
貪瞋痴でやるものは不善で
例えば会社に行く場合は
私はいっぱい金を儲けて贅沢して威張ってやろうと思う感じで会社に行くと
立派な会社に行ってるんだから
すごく自分のなんて言いますか
肩書きとしてそれで威張っているならば
もうかわいそうに
不善行為で
人間は仕事をするべきであって
そのお金で自分も幸福になって
家族も幸福にして
社会のことも国のこともして
人間らしく生きていなくちゃいけないんだということで仕事に行くと
善行為で気持ちで決めるんです
と　以上でございます
いろいろご質問があったら聞いてください